there is a current human characteristic
that's always been around but it's hot
is called i have this belief that if i
tear down somebody else i'm gonna feel
better this is huge momentum in the
human race right now and it is
remarkably off the most guaranteed way
to never get happier is by putting your
energy on tearing down other people if
all your energy is telling yourself and
the world why all these other people
suck you will [ __ ] lose how do i know
this because in my one part of my life
sports gary i tear down patriot fans
because i'm so hurt that my team isn't
winning that that's where my energy goes
and that's my most unhappy place but
that's fake life that's sports you
[ __ ] are doing this in real
life [ __ ] stomping tearing down other
[ __ ] people is just a [ __ ] tell
that you're not [ __ ] winning you may
be tricking the 90 that aren't seeing
the world for what it is but you're not
tricking the 10 that now and for
everybody who just saw this and realized
[ __ ] i'm doing that please use this
video as the one that stops it will
really make your life better